hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh may 24th what's going on
how are ya how's it going how are you
how are you
um it's [ __ ] hilarious
my producer was telling me like jesus
christ bill what the [ __ ] did you talk
about in the last podcast everybody's
coming at me
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
billy [ __ ] bummed out the last
podcast and everybody [ __ ] attacks
[ __ ] andrew
leave the guy alone all right he's not
the reason for
any of my [ __ ] i'm going this is all
good [ __ ] i'm i'm working my way through
the catacombs
you know i'm gonna have good days and
bad days all right everybody [ __ ]
relax
okay i like this [ __ ] i like how every
time you
do anything then people reach out just
to know you can [ __ ] call somebody
um i'm so [ __ ] up those messages make
me angry
i know it's not you it's me uh but
anyway i appreciate the concern i'm fine
all right i'm not gonna off myself i'm
just [ __ ] going through some
depressing [ __ ]
i got kids i'm not gonna off myself all
right the [ __ ] bruins are looking
great they're up three games to one i'm
not
yeah everything's fine all right i just
got some [ __ ] i need to [ __ ]
clean out of the attic there
um so i can stop [ __ ] you know being
a douche to people that i love
around me you know and
the cycle you get a car and you get a
car
trying to do some oprah [ __ ] here um
anyway anyways
i've been on me shut off my phone here
if you guys are into the real housewives
which somehow i'm finally into which is
really
been a great thing for me and my wife
i'm actually i just [ __ ] watch it now
and i've i've given in and i just make
fun of them and it's the one show where
i can talk
and just interrupt and my wife doesn't
give a [ __ ] because there's really
nothing
to follow and because of that
i've now been listening to this podcast
called uh
uh guess what crappin's now or whatever
it's it's
making fun of the it does the review of
the uh andy cohen show when he gets them
all together
which is like sportscenter for the for
the real housewives and he gets them all
going again
and i just been listening to that
podcast and i can't get those [ __ ]
impressions i don't even know what women
they're imitating but they're [ __ ]
hilarious and one of them does this
incredible andy cohen
impression um
i don't know somehow yeah
i'm trying to uh i don't know i got
sucked into all of that i just
i [ __ ] just gave in i gave in and
uh you know sometimes you know in a
relationship
if you just give up sometimes if you
just give up
in certain areas it's fun it is okay
you don't have to always win you know
but it is nice to win sometimes
you know which is something that you
know a lot of these broads
are not in touch with you know because
if you're going to [ __ ] win on some
point it's like okay
i guess we'll do that then and then you
got to deal with their [ __ ] mood
it's like that's you you're not you're
not coming along for the ride here
no what i'm just sitting here don't do
that passive aggressive [ __ ]
why are you yelling you gasping me i
want to go home
that's how that used to go now so what
you do now
what you gotta do is you have to be like
okay so my options are basically
do what you want let me finish do what
you want to do
or we actually get to do what i want to
do
but you're going to pout the whole time
i'm not going to pout
look at your face come on you got a
little [ __ ]
reverse selfie camera there take a
picture of your face right now tell me
that's not pouting right now
you know you look like that dog nobody
picked down at the pound
all right so um
yeah yeah i can't even get into the
silly one we had uh
yesterday they're all silly fights after
a while i miss having her on the podcast
but you know
we got the kids now so it's like when i
do the podcast she has to watch the kids
so
one of these days i'm gonna have uh
somebody over here watching the kids and
i'll get her back on the podcast because
um i am presenting way too much of a
one-sided
look at my life um but anyway
uh yesterday saturday because the
pandemic i didn't have any shows or
anything so i just hanged with my wife
and we went out got a babysitter and we
went out
and i went to an art show
which is something i would never do
back in the day like i was so homophobic
i couldn't even go to an art show
it was like paintings like there's not
guys [ __ ] beating each other up and
being all sweaty rolling all over each
other
i'm not going to this this is too gay
right it's [ __ ] hilarious then you
see what i'm watching it's like i don't
know bill
i think looking at a painting you might
have some tendencies there bill you keep
watching all these [ __ ] you like
wrestling bill
these guys walking around oiled up
shirtless
flexing their pecs uh but you know that
was that was
it was a different time so um
so anyway so i skipped into this gallery
yesterday getting totally
confident in my sexuality um
with my wife it's the second time i've
done that and i have thoroughly
enjoyed it both times
it's it's it's a completely different uh
mix of people and the two times that
she has taken me to these events
is they're actually paintings of stuff
i recognize in other words it's stuff
from this dimension where like you know
i don't like that [ __ ] where it just
looked
like somebody had a temper tantrum and
there was paint close by
um i do
get it a little bit looking at a canvas
and if there's colors that i like that
make
give me a a a happy mood feeling i guess
but it's like i ain't paying [ __ ] you
know i wouldn't buy one of those things
i'm just saying i mean if i was gunna
it's like dude
you just [ __ ] vomited all over this
canvas and you you want how much for
this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here this looks like a
casino rug
um which by the way i learned
that the reason why they have those
super colorful crazy
patterns on the casino oaks is because
people are spilling drinks and yakking
and doing all kinds of [ __ ] dropping
their crap [ __ ] rocks on it
it all sort of blends in um
it's a way to keep it uh
not looking so drab and shabby or
whatever so
anyway so we went to this thing and uh
got to give a shout out
i want to make sure i'm saying the right
people i think they were the perez
brothers
they had this [ __ ] sick painting
of um you know the low riders with the
hydraulics and the guys stand
next to the car it's like they're
holding a game boy whatever the [ __ ]
that is
they drew a picture of two of those cars
with you know two of the guys doing it
with the sick [ __ ] paint jobs
and then a bunch of people standing
around watching it and then everything
else there was nothing else there
everything else was just a white
background let me see here
the perez brothers
ah [ __ ] come on bill
i picked the wrong latino name
here we go
now wait a minute i followed him on
instagram god damn it
did i say the wrong name
no i found him the perez bros bros
they have they make the these uh
like these pain this is like something i
look at and i like
i like that [ __ ] so i mean i i didn't
think that i was going to go into that
gallery yesterday
and see uh you know
a painting of cars custom cars and stuff
so
anyway we did that we had a great time
my wife's over the moon that i'm
actually doing this stuff and i'm
actually in it
into it and then um
all right we gotta i'm i'm back people i
just had to cut something out because i
would my wife would have [ __ ] killed
me if i
anyway um
what was i gonna say um so anyway after
the [ __ ]
um the uh
the gallery you know
and i thought it was gonna be like a
bunch of people walking around with
those big black
black frame glasses you know
you know look a bunch of weirdos and
stuff and it wasn't it was a really cool
mix of people
so afterward i go all right how about uh
you know how about a little meat thing
here we'll go down to a cigar bar
because i made the mistake of smoking
one last week so now i'm kind of back on
them
um and i went down and i smoked a cigar
and i got to tell you i didn't enjoy it
i
enjoyed the cigar but i didn't enjoy
being back into that world
and uh i've decided i'm not smoking
again until
uh my buddy comes out here in like june
and then the next time i'll smoke after
that is
once in july when i'm in vegas and then
i don't know if i go to like a football
game in the fall i really just want them
to be
like last week when i smoked one i
hadn't smoked in three four months
bobby kelly was in town
we went over to a buddy's house he made
this unbelievable steak and like that's
the way you do it you don't just do it
because you you smoked it now you got
the craving then it just then you just
defeaned
and uh i don't want to do that so um
i'm back off him again um
yeah for a while or whatever
um i don't know i'm trying to learn how
to do [ __ ] in moderation basically
so anyway so we went there and i smoked
it and i was just like i enjoyed it but
i was just like ah [ __ ] now i'm doing
this again
so that was sort of a you know people
they were cool though i love cigar
peoples and the cigar was delicious but
i just felt like ah [ __ ] why did i do
that
i had my second one too close to the
last time
so now it's going to get its hooks in me
again so now i just got to white knuckle
it for the rest of [ __ ]
you know the next couple two three weeks
and then towards the end of next month
or whatever i'll have one and i'll be
all right
that's how i plan on doing it so um
then we ended up uh i needed a new
hoodie and i'm trying to find a [ __ ]
hoodie
they're not making hoodies anymore
everything's all about the pullovers and
all of that [ __ ]
and then i finally ended up finding one
and i liked everything about it except
the people that made it
had their name on the right shoulder
like
right where you'd have like a tattoo and
i didn't like it because it kind of made
it look like i worked for them
um so i came home and i was able to
remove it
and uh and i'm psyched that's all i need
i just need a nice [ __ ] hoodie
because all my hoodies were getting
[ __ ] worn out and i was kind of
coming down to the point where the only
one i really had was that was still in
decent shape
was one from the jimmy kimmel show and
you can't walk around
outside your house wearing a tv credit
or else you look like a douche like oh
look at me i'm in show business right
which speaking of which and i wanna i
want you guys to find
i think i was in a porno
i really thought about what i was
talking about the other day i think i'm
in the opening the cold open to a porno
all right and i want you guys to find it
here's the deal i was driving my car
up on mulholland i'm telling this story
again in case you missed the last
episode
and i came around the corner and there
was two chicks wearing
next to nothing oiled up walking a dog
down the street
i mean they were basically naked right
and i was like what the [ __ ] i
immediately thought it was
like a prank show um
and the more i thought it i was like
that they was stealing a shot and
stealing a shot means you don't have a
permit to shoot
so they probably just pulled up and said
okay you know we're gonna do like a
drone thing or something
if somebody was shooting it from
somewhere and they just had them walking
down the street so
if you see a porno and it starts off it
was a black chick and either a latin
latin chick or an italian chick or
something like that
and i'm on the same side of the street
it's a green jaguar and if you see some
bald freckled guy like oh
god like what the [ __ ] is that that's me
and i want credit that i'm in that
[ __ ] video
um so there you go see now back in the
day
you know there was a thing where i don't
i don't know if it ever worked
but she always heard these stories of
how these beautiful
women got discovered like you know uh
this
or like even like guys like i remember
that that kid from the terminator we saw
him in a mall
casting director sam and a mom were like
oh let's make this person famous
and you know possibly [ __ ] up their life
you know their lives right
and there was always these stories about
like um i wasn't even in show business
i was just pretty and they noticed me
right so people were like
you know it's not the way it is now
where the kardashians showed you what
you have to do is [ __ ] blow somebody
on camera
and then you'll be a billionaire right
that that that option
didn't exist back then all right
you were either a commercial actor a tv
actor
a movie star or you were in port
you couldn't just jump all around like
these free agents in the [ __ ] nba
going where's the best deal for me yeah
right so there was this thing out here
where women would go
dress hot because they knew that [ __ ]
agents were down there and
managers and [ __ ] right and then the
managers would go down there dude you
gotta go down there there's a bunch of
hot chicks right and then they would go
down there
and then it was that weird dance right
the weird dance like i want to rep you
slash [ __ ] you i want to be represented
but i don't want to [ __ ] you there was
this whole
[ __ ] game that was going on
so back in the day if i saw that
like when i lived out here in the 90s
i would have been like if i saw that i
would be like oh
well they're going extra hard trying to
get a [ __ ] agent
um or a manager
but now it's like well they could just
do that
on instagram from the safety of their
own home
start their own brand and not have a
manager or an agent
and just be like you know like oh yeah
here's my titties you like these yeah
you [ __ ] like them you know whatever
the [ __ ] they do
and make [ __ ] a whole bunch of money
and become like an influencer
right there's no reason to do that
anymore unless they didn't pay their
cable bill
but even though their cell phone bill i
don't know
i'm convinced it was a porno i have no
idea um
and i'm still also i i watched um
i owe dirty harry the movie dirty harry
an apology because i lumped it in
to all of those those [ __ ] uh
movies that would rip off i probably of
dirty harry where they were basically
doing the uh
the white cop goes into the not white
neighborhood
because he's going to clean it up and
never address that that neighborhood is
like that because of
the oppression of white people dirty
harry is not that movie
it's a [ __ ] great movie and um
it doesn't even have that i don't feel
it even has that element in there so i
wanted to
uh correct what the [ __ ] i said i
watched the rest of dirty harry and i
got to tell you man
that [ __ ] scene where he's standing
on the bridge
and then the bus comes underneath which
by the way he did that [ __ ] stunt
it's just
it's [ __ ] i don't know how he knew to
stand on that bridge but it was [ __ ]
like
it's [ __ ] it's such a [ __ ] badass
shot and that piece of [ __ ] he's in the
bus
oh my god he slaps that fat kid um
the kid's crying and [ __ ] um
that [ __ ] the look on that actor's
face when he sees dirty harry up in the
bridge it's just [ __ ] priceless so
i watched magnum force and now i'm
watching the enforcer so here you go so
the first
dirty harry came out in 71. magnum force
was 73 and then uh the enforcer was 76.
so so far the cars that clint has driven
i think he had a i think it was a 1968
ford custom 500
was the first one then he had a 72 ford
ltd
green i love a green car he had that in
magnum force
and then for whatever reason in the
enforcer i kind of like this choice he's
driving a
car that's like four years old it's a 72
plymouth no longer a ford he's got a
plymouth satellite
um what are you doing harry well he
asked for a car
okay well i'm gonna give him a car
he drives it through the front of the
liquor store if you're into body count
the one that has the the highest body
count
is uh magnum force comes out at 30
bodies
all right just to break it down for you
because i know a lot of you play fantasy
football
there's four creeps in a car then
there's four guys in a liquor store
three in and one out
and there's a great thing where he
throws one of the guys in the liquor
store
throws this kid with a numbered shirt
from the 70s
into a display inside the liquor store
and uh i got a kick out of that i was
like that that really is
the cinematic version of being a kid in
the 70s
you had a numbered shirt and there was
some adult manhandling you that was
really not part of your family
whatsoever
and then they you'd get thrown into
something and then your parents would
just be like well you know what the [ __ ]
did you say well what would you shut up
listen to him
when the gym teacher tells you to do
jumping jacks you do the [ __ ] jumping
jacks right
so four creeps in the car four guys
three guys in the liquor store
the driver outside six people at the
pool
four people in a high rise uh a hooker
kills
a pimp kills a hooker and then the pimp
gets killed
four hoods in a high hideout five cops
and one police commissioner for a grand
total of 30.
phenomenal films phenomenal films
my favorite one right now is i like the
enforcer because it's actually
really fits in today with like um
all the progressive and i'm not saying
this in a negative way but all the ways
things have changed because not all of
progressive [ __ ] has been bad
okay not all of feminism is bad not all
about being a hipster
is bad where people say you know
hipsters do like a lot of good [ __ ]
and they do know where the good food is
it's not all [ __ ] bad right
it's like my act you know there's a
couple of stinkers in there but you know
overall i think there's some good jokes
i think you can hang with me for an hour
um so in the 1972 one i really recommend
you watch him in order so you can really
just follow the development of
harry callahan in the 1972 one the
enforcer
i just started watching i'm about 20
minutes in so
um it's very progressive in that
you know
the first one is
his partner's latino probably played by
an italian guy who's kidding who right
but anyway it's supposed to be latino
maybe he's latino i don't know
and then the next one his partner's
black
and then this one i think he's gonna get
a woman partner
which isn't good because when you're a
partner with harry callahan you're gonna
get paralyzed you're gonna get blown up
in a mailbox like shit's gonna [ __ ]
happen to you right
i should have said spoiler alert for all
of this [ __ ] so in the enforcer
they want to have more women on the
force
right and they're explaining why and the
ladies going my name is
miz something or other right so the
establisher is the feminist
and she's going how you know we're going
to try to get rid of the
the neanderthal or neanderthal however
you say that word
element on the cops and clint's just
looking and i think we need more females
on it
and this is his response to more women
on the force was
he just goes well
isn't that fancy
and i'm going to tell you right now i'm
stealing that
the next time somebody said we need more
women coaches in the nfl i'm just be
like well
well isn't that fancy
[Laughter]
oh why can't they just
go to the wnba and build a league no
they don't wanna they wanna go to the
ones that's already built
i'm kidding there's football fans that
have both genitalia bill
it's time to be progressive well isn't
that fancy
um all right i have uh
i'm trying to go through what my walk-on
music is gonna be for my tour i always
have something that i come out to
and i i've narrowed it down to a few uh
and one of the ones that i've just been
fast because i woke up one day and the
song was in my head
was paula abdul the way that you love me
so i find this song
fascinating because i've thought about
the song
i don't know why but there's so many
different ways to read this song
so it's this chick she's dating this
[ __ ] dude who's you know he's got
all of this stuff and her she's
basically saying it's not all the stuff
that you have and it's all this [ __ ]
that you're doing
it's the way that you love me but she's
really listing
all of this [ __ ] and she knows
all of this [ __ ] that he has right down
to the point she can not only
inventory all the stuff he has she can
also make it rhyme while she's doing it
so she's very
she's well aware of what's i'll read you
some of the lyrics
um it's uh it ain't the clothes that you
wear
it ain't the things that you buy it
ain't your house on the hill
hey it ain't the plane that you fly
this guy has a house on a hill he's
flying planes right
and ain't your black limousine didn't
you
90 foot roll of the eyes yacht little
dick joke in there
and ain't the things that you'll get it
ain't the things you got
it ain't the money or the diamond rings
honey i ain't impressed with your
material things it's the way that you
love me
burp um
so this guy's got a 90-foot yacht or
maybe she said he's got a big dick i
think that that's what it's supposed to
be 90 foot yet i mean it's a million a
meter
so that's about 30 million bucks right
there if i do the metrics right thank
you motogp for
me learning the metric system a little
bit um
it's not any of that [ __ ] it's the way
that that that he loves her
they ain't your friends at the top and
ain't there fortune and fame so you know
celebrity
and you know rich [ __ ] people uh it
ain't your heavy connections it ain't
the hollywood game
it ain't the fame famous people or the
parties they throw
honey i ain't impressed with all the
people you know
it's the way that you love me in the
heat of the night
it's the way that you love me baby
that's like the way she goes berber
um when you're loving me right baby and
the things that you do
baby makes me crazy for you all right
so this guy's doing all of this stuff
and he's also putting it on her
basically
all right so here's hey
the trips to brazil it ain't the
weekends in rome
and ain't the french riviera you know
i'd rather stay home
it ain't the bahamas it ain't monaco
honey i ain't impressed with all the
places we go
so at first my first listen to this song
i know by the way i know how ridiculous
this is
but i just love how many different ways
you can this is people think oh this is
just a dumb pop song
you can this is like going to a museum
and looking at uh
there's all these different
interpretations
all right so you can just to read this
at face value
where this check is just with this guy
because he's rich
right and what she's she's saying this
stuff allegedly to him
but she's really saying it to herself
she's trying
to convince herself that she's not in
love with the lifestyle
it's that she really loves this guy now
this is the way
i i interpret it for years
and then the other day it was in my head
and i was sort of laughing about the
song
um and then i was starting well wait a
minute
maybe it's that she really loves this
guy
but he has all of this stuff and he's
around all of these people and all of
this temptations
all the temptation that she is [ __ ]
worried
that she's gonna lose the guy
right some other broad's gonna come
moving in on on a turf here on that
90-foot yacht if you know what i mean
there
um so i think what it is for her is
she's trying
she's waiting for this guy to drop the
ring he hasn't done it yet
so her way to feel in control
is she has to kind of like knock down
all of this [ __ ] that he's like he's the
guy knows how to fly a plane he's got a
black limousine
he's taking her all of these places and
giving her diamond rings
hitting all the hot cities around the
[ __ ] world
and you know it's on his dime and then
she she says that she's not impressed
which you know is [ __ ] rude right
if you take it at face value but it's
like oh she's nervous
that she's just like you know
this little passing fanta fancy thing
and then you know he's going to move on
to somebody else
you know and she's tap dancing in the
video so it's like she feels like she
has to always [ __ ] be
looking good and doing a little dance
like huh see my tits still perky enough
for you
hey right and then say she's not
impressed and you know i'd rather stay
home right
she's just trying to stay grounded i
don't know i think she's worried the
whole thing's going to go away
and she's going to waste the best years
of her life
and then the next guy she gets with is
just gonna have a regular dick and
drive a [ __ ] plymouth satellite going
well
isn't that fancy
[Music]
um anyway let's talk some [ __ ]
nhl playoffs the only series that i have
time to watch
uh bruins versus the capitals i only
caught the third period
um [ __ ] i heard miller got hurt
i know he got hurt and i guess we have
to maybe i don't know
someone from back from back east the
family back east was saying
that you know one of our guys needed to
go out and go [ __ ] up some guy on the
[ __ ] capitals it's like no you know
what we need to do
we need to send them home packing that's
that's what we need to do okay
and um
i don't know i i think the capitals are
a great team and i actually think the
next game is a must win because i don't
want to be 3-2 with them and then
and then the next game is do they tie it
up that's what i love about a seven-game
series is you're down three games to one
and it's looking bleak and all you have
to do is win the next game
and the pressure goes back on the other
person so i am actually nervous
about game five um i want this thing to
be
over and done with and uh i got to give
a shout out to ovechkin that hit on
marshawn
as much as i love brad marchanda and i
love the bruins
dude there is anything better than a
[ __ ] clean open ice hit i mean
[ __ ] blasted the helmet right off
them who's [ __ ] amazing
and you watch that and then you look at
a guy like wilson who once again
there's a guy down on the ice he's like
[ __ ] cross-checking him
and the nhl awards the capitals with
like a power play
it's like i don't i don't get what
they're doing with that [ __ ] serial
killer
and what sucks about him is he can play
and you look at that hit
ovechkin did on marshawn it's like dude
that's the way you do it
you have the size and you have the skill
set to do that and you can put the puck
in the back of the net
there's no reason for you to be doing
all of this other [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] reason for you to be
doing it i i just don't get it
and um
like i said i know people always try to
compare marshawn to wilson it's just
like you know you got a guy
five foot [ __ ] nothing 185 pounds and
then you got this
[ __ ] other guy who's six foot four
230 pounds i'm telling
this guy's gonna end [ __ ] careers
um but whatever i mean
it ain't on him the the [ __ ] nhl just
lets him play that way it's really a
strange thing and
i was actually nervous when we went up
like four to one
and i'm like please keep wilson on the
bench because he's going to go out there
and just
end somebody's [ __ ] season which i
guess one of the other guys did with the
[ __ ] hit to the head
um that is the one aspect of [ __ ] the
nhl hockey that i've always loved the
fights and physical and all of that type
of [ __ ] of the game
but i always hated those claude lemieux
players
that would just take it to the point of
like oh you guys are better than us so
we're just going to take out one of your
best [ __ ] players or whatever
um the old samuelsons that type of [ __ ]
um so if they could get rid of that you
know and just have hits like [ __ ]
ovechkin get i mean that's
how how can you get mad at that it was a
thing of beauty
um all right so critical game five for
the bruins i think the pressure's on the
bruins
i don't want to be 3-2 with the capitals
i want to [ __ ]
just put them to bed rest up then miller
can come back
and see who we play uh next round um
all right and with that the celtics had
their uh
first game against the upstart brooklyn
nets
you know just an upstart team you know
pulling themselves up by the bootstrap
with uh
a bunch of no names like james harden
kevin durant kyrie irving blake griffin
deandre jordan just a bunch of
knock-around guys
that came out to compete for the love of
the game
oh the nba is the worst i i just hope
they
baseball got out of this i feel like
baseball did even though there's still
teams that spend a lot of money but
those
looking back as much as as fun as it was
to see the red sox win in o4
if you look at that period during
baseball it was [ __ ] ridiculous
it really was 200 190 180 200 million
29 million dollar team i think the
yankees had one time red sox right
behind him it was
it was [ __ ] ridiculous um
and you just spend the whole season just
waiting for these two
behemoth teams to clash and it makes the
other 28 teams [ __ ] irrelevant i've
known i've said it forever but i'm going
to continue [ __ ] saying it
until uh something is done about it it's
just like
i look i don't mind if you pick up a
free agent or whatever that's this whole
[ __ ] nine guys all go to the same
[ __ ] team
they won by 40. oh yeah they should have
they showed up
um i don't think it's good for the
league i don't think it's good
uh but
people still sit down and watch it so i
should say it's not good for the game i
think it is good for the league
because people then tune in because they
want to see the
the dream it's like they have dream
teams within
the nba where they used to have the
dream team and it would go over and they
would play like [ __ ]
you know portugal
be dunking on them putting their nuts in
their face i mean i don't know i
i don't uh i don't know that's not the
kind of sports i want to watch i want to
watch and
i like you know every game if you can go
for the chargers versus the dolphins
that [ __ ]
game like that's what i would like to
watch rather than uh
this other [ __ ] so all right that's
it let me see if the reads and all that
stuff came in at this point
babe it's just the way that you love me
[ __ ] i'm not impressed
hilarious jesus christ
what a thing to say all right four reads
here we go
oh look who it is everybody endochino
uh have you ever felt self-conscious
about getting dressed up
um when you wear clothes that fit and
feel comfortable you will
you will be a better you indochino
offers completely customized fitted
suits shirts casual wear and it
and more at surprisingly and more at
surprisingly affordable prices
every piece is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail
choose everything about your suit from
the fabric lapel
monogram and state statement linings
you can create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly
the best part inducino suits start at
just 299 dollars
with all customizations included shop
for your next
best look or book a virtual style
consultation at indochino.com right now
you can get 50 off any purchase of a
3.99
or more by using code bur at checkout
that's 50
off a purchase of 3.99 at indochino
i n d o c h i n
o dot com promo code burr
oh look who it is
me undies look at your pylon team do do
do do me undies me undies it's [ __ ]
boring not
a dream what about the other 28
are they supposed to sit around and act
like you're great you
really aren't you [ __ ] lazy bastards
win a championship the old school way
with soft underwears
summer is coming and for so many of us
it's
it's the season of discomfort
it's hot out and if you could sit around
and just your underwear you would me
undies wants to make this the summer of
comfort
and they want you to know what um
what if you want to sit around wait
meonis wants to make this summer
this the summer of comfort and they want
you to know that if you want to sit
around in your underwear
that's absolutely allowed they got great
copy me undies
great comfortable and ex i just can't
read it that's the problem i'm too
dumb but this is really i can't imagine
who writes this and how
how much how deflated they are when they
hear me read it after all the work they
put into it
um get comfortable and express yourself
this summer with undies in the classic
in classic and bold colors and fun and
adventurous prints
rushing home to change into something
more comfortable is the thing is a thing
of the past you know exactly what i'm
talking about stay
comfy in me undies all day gennany socks
bralettes and more choose from endless
styles in sizes
extra small to 4xl which is what i'm
going to be if i keep eating oreo
cookies
with their sustainably soft micro modal
modal
and ultra light breathe fabrics me
undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any first
time purchasers you can get
15 off and free shipping me undies and
als
myandi's also has their problem-free
philosophy
um if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason
they'll refund it or exchange it no
caveats ooh big word
no questions to get your 15 off your
first order and free shipping go to
myunders.com that's meundies.com
for 15 off your first order and free
shipping
all right what do we got here oh we got
a couple more here
um butcher box
butcher box are you itching for the
outdoors
i'm not itching i got all my me undies
there
um it's barbecue season baby
uh baby oh baby get ready for that
get ready for that summer cookout paul
abdul wrote this
it's the barbecue season
uh get ready for that summer cookout
talk about the flexibility the product
allows for an impromptu gathering yeah i
always got a bunch of fresh
grass-fed grass-fed [ __ ] uh uh
grass-finished [ __ ] grassy meat
no antibiotics no [ __ ] uh they didn't
slap these cows around i got
fresh sustainably sourced [ __ ] uh
pork chops
ready to go when i do i got him in my
freezer
i love it i actually grabbed a steak the
other day
we didn't know what we were gonna eat i
just took it out i [ __ ] thawed this
[ __ ] and i ate it it was delicious
um anyways you know what's going to
happen
so prepare for it you're going to have
an impromptu gathering
not everyone has convenient access to
high quality meat
luck well paul abdul does you're 90 foot
yacht luckily today's sponsor butcher
box believes everyone deserves high
quality humanely sourced meat
and when you sign up now you get a free
bbq bundle in your first box
two new york strip steaks six burgers
and five pounds of drumsticks
all for free in your first box who does
not love
free meat every month butcher box ships
a curated selection of high quality meat
right to my home
no added antibiotics or hormones ever
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals
um i can customize my box or go with one
of theirs either way i get exactly what
i want
options like 100 grass-fed and finished
beef that's what i was trying to say
free-range organic chickens get over
here
humanely raised pork wild caught alaskan
salmon you don't know what they're gonna
do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon
it's the way meat should be and they
even have free shipping nationwide
except alaska and hawaii
for a limited time butcher box is
offering new members a free
bbq bundle in their first box that's two
new york strip steaks six burgers and
five pounds of drumsticks
all for free in your first box just go
to butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com to get a free
bbq bundle in your first box
all right all right here we go let's get
to
the questions the questions here on the
podcast all right
what do we got here uh oh look at this
bill great emails
cbd cbd soda
hey billy bonham uh was listening to
your previous podcast regarding your
apprehension to drinking alcohol
uh you don't want to break the streak
but you also mentioned it'd be nice to
get a buzz every once in a while
have you heard of cbd soda it's exactly
what it sounds like flavored soda water
with 25 milligrams of cbd in it that
sounds like a lot
it has helped enormously with my own
drinking habit and gives you a pleasant
calming buzz
without getting you messed up out of
your mind uh
lets you get on with the rest of your
day also no hangover which is a huge
plus
well that's amazing i don't know i i i
think you know
i need to figure out who what the [ __ ]
happened to me and who the [ __ ] i am
here
first before i start going around in an
altered state
just make sure to do your research so
that you're getting a high quality
reputable product well can you recommend
one
the one downside is it can make you a
little sleepy
but that can subside after an hour or
just take a nap
all right so obviously don't do this
while driving there are sugarless and
natural flavored options too so you can
fend off the calories
dude the we are we are in like the
golden age of getting [ __ ] up
i mean they're going to come up with
ways we can literally have your cake and
eat it you can get
[ __ ] up you won't be belligerent
there's no hangover and you won't get
fat i mean that's about there's still
going to be a price to pay i'm sure
you're still
killing brain cells or whatever but
there is like a
[Music]
i don't know what am i looking for to
say here there is a [ __ ]
i was just thinking of mushrooms for
some reason so i completely lost my
[ __ ] train of thought what i was
trying to say
i don't know i have no idea what the
what the [ __ ] is going on with my brain
maybe i need to drink this [ __ ] [ __ ]
here
i'm just saying back in the day you got
[ __ ] up you paid the price
and a lot of people died at 27. it
seemed nowadays you can just [ __ ]
like
it's like i want to be [ __ ] up but i
still want to build a house
we have the perfect marijuana for that
you know
um this guy ends it with up yours [ __ ]
i like that all right
pool cover now i had a problem with my
little splash about
i've refused to call my pool of
flashabout okay if you can go into your
pool and at no point
you know is there a place where you can
just have your your feet
are touching the bottom and your head is
still well out of the water you
you do not have a pool you have an
in-ground above ground pool
um all right dear billy sunspot
i have a solar's pool cover as well
or should i say had i had the same
problem you did i left it out and it got
ruined
i didn't know it'd be like having a pet
that required that much maintenance
i started asking questions to my
brother-in-law who works at a tech
company
that dabbles in solar power he basically
told me that solar technology in general
is where computers were in the 70s
except that people think it's as good as
computers are now
he suggested getting aluminum or some
other metal
to cover the pool some heavy-duty gloves
so i don't
burn my hands so you don't burn your
hands when moving it
he said essentially it's the same thing
this was just disheartening sincerely
guy with small balls and cold pool
oh yeah well they'll get it there i mean
look what they've done with getting
[ __ ] up
you know um
i don't know i don't know if i'm done
with alcohol forever i told my wife like
uh
if we ever go back to france like i
might come up but then i just don't want
to go through having
taken me [ __ ] six years to quit again
um
i don't know i think i'm in a really
good place here despite
you know my last podcast i am i'm just
just going through some [ __ ] here so i i
need to [ __ ] do this
and i'm going to and it's really going
to benefit my kids and now i actually
kind of realize
why subconsciously maybe i waited so
long to have kids
so i just really needed to pull the
handbrake on the runaway freight train
of dysfunction of you know and i'm not
just coming down
on my family tree just like in general
just generally speaking you know the
fallout of everybody trying
to fix you know [ __ ] you got to
understand it first so now that i do i
just feel like uh
you know i'll be a way better parent
hopefully all right malibu deck collapse
what's up you freckled freak
please do a story on the malibu deck
collapse i didn't see that the news
coverage is [ __ ] hysterical the
interviews of the pain and suffering
they
endured is beyond imaginable
how they felt the mind blowing 15 feet
to the jagged right i didn't hear about
this
jagged rocks below
uh with winegat glasses and caviar
without dying is beyond me
oh my god the news coverage shows them
limping to where mercedes and bmw
and bmws i almost pissed my pants
i sure hope they get the support they
need to rebuild their 50
000 deck on their 30 million dollar home
well haven't you ever heard that saying
that your health is everything
um now i know i seem like i'm
rich shaming but i'm old school and
don't give a [ __ ] all right i can go
with that
i was born in the 70s and grew up
talking
uh taking ass whooping whooping from
bullies while the teachers laughed
when america wasn't full of snatch-faced
sissies
um or maybe you're just still hurt from
all of that
and this is the protective place you're
still in
i mean don't you wish somebody helped
you out back then so when
or if you're saying there's been an
over-correction
um i don't even think there's an
over-correction in caring
i just think that there's a select group
of [ __ ] sociopaths
white women that are there are
are grabbing the steering wheel of this
and really ignoring
people of color and all of that and
they're making it about themselves and
it's a power grab
that's really kind of what's going on
here i think
uh check out the videos on youtube and
carry on i saw your show at madison
square garden two years ago
on mushrooms with my wife nice and she's
been hooked ever since
to mushrooms or to my act dude you see
anything on mushrooms you can be like
dude
i [ __ ] like this this is good [ __ ]
um all right ketamine
kid of mine greetings and love you
freckled [ __ ]
as someone who has self-healed from a
childhood of abuse slash neglect
who has been a bit timid about trying
shrooms and [ __ ]
i highly highly recommend
wait a minute this guy spelled keto mean
k-e-t-o-m-i-n-e
then then he or she spells it
k-o-t-m-i-n-e
and m-d-m-a
m-d-m-a is a safer version of ecstasy
mda
is not cut for parties with random [ __ ]
yeah dude i i'm not i'm not i'm not
going into
that world you know what the first song
i heard
i just thought of was the part where
madonna's moaning
in that song uh smack my
[ __ ] up like all of a sudden i'll just
be in that thing and she's in the
background i'll just hear her voice
[Music]
what was that robert plant um i live in
oakland
san francisco and ketamine shrooms have
been
decriminalized for therapy
wow can you imagine if this [ __ ]
actually works
what if it actually [ __ ] works and
you could like cure people
at the very least of the pain that
happened to them and then what if you
could then
give it to people that have inflicted
pain and then they could [ __ ] cure
whatever made them
the pain that happened to them that made
them hurt other people
then how would they try and separate us
then how could they pit us against each
other
um when mushrooms take half
a day where mushrooms take half a day i
think is what you want to say a dose of
k will get you back to life in
30 hours dude did you write this
while high on this [ __ ] when mushrooms
take half a day okay that'd be 12 hours
a dose of k will get you back to life in
30 hour
did you mean a third of an hour but you
feel like you died and came back squeaky
clean
a nice fondle of the chakras man
um i was tossed to the street at night
by my mother at 10 years old
for calling my father upset due to my
stepfather's drunken destruction
oh and she chose him my stepfather was
molested
and took it all out on me growing up i
didn't know the molestation until i was
an adult
but [ __ ] was [ __ ] a poor [ __ ] up
redheaded stepchild from
from vermont so i relate to your new
england ashy bald ginger [ __ ] soul
um nothing has helped me like a week
with
k and mdma i like how you've gotten in
touch with your chakras but still if
you're gonna say that you relate to me
as another man
i'm assuming you're straight that you
then have to call me a [ __ ]
ashy bald ginger [ __ ] soul so it doesn't
seem too
gay um i let some hippies take me to
burning man which is an amazing art show
totally better than my
sarcastic non-new age mind thought it
would be jesus christ did i write this
[ __ ]
you sound like me i was dosed and
finally broke down
cried spent the week on a bike just
peddling and letting go of childhood
drama
that sounds great i tried dmt once and
every time i see a mosque i see what
started out
started most of our cultures uh the word
dmt
brings the world dmt brings you is
exactly what the ceiling of the mosque
looked like
religion is sober people trying to
recreate one person's heavy drug fueled
weekend
wow religion is sober people trying to
recreate
one person's heavy drug fueled weekend
that's pretty [ __ ] wild all right
cheated on fiance with bottle service
girl
oh boy come on guys i'm not a therapist
you're going too deep here bill a little
over a month ago i went on a bachelor
trip and i hooked up with the bottle
service girl that worked our vip booth
it's a wild story that i'd love to tell
every detail but long story short
the bottle service girl found out i was
engaged after google searching my name
the day after we hooked up
i played at a big d1 college and had a
sh
i don't want to read all your details uh
i don't have facebook or i don't have
any social medias but now i've learned
to never underestimate the investigative
work of a group of girls at brunch
drinking bottomless
mimosas and yes of course i would have
given her a fake name but it was my
credit card
oh my god oh my god this is like this is
like a
vip booth and i had to give her my
driver's license to verify the transit
anyway she found my fiance's instagram
and told her everything that happened
before i even boarded my connecting
flight home
i was picked up from the airport and
immediately confronted by my fiance
literally i was busted four hours after
the bottle service girl dropped me off
at the airport
i deleted everything on my phone except
i didn't clear my google search to which
my fiance finds
how long until molly kicks in oh boy
if anyone is interested about 30 minutes
and google is just kicking my ass left
and right i have never taken molly
before and
some life advice for your listeners if
you're trying to stay
faithful to your significant other it's
the last drug you should ever take me
and my fiance are still together but my
life has been turned upside down
everything i do is under a microscope
and this is something
i never i've never put up with with
other relationships and i'm really
struggling with it
the bachelor trip i went on was not mine
but my fiance is telling me that
i can't have my own bachelor trip well
it sounds like you already had one dude
i know that trust is gone and it's going
to take years to gain it back but i
don't think i can set a precedent of
giving up this much
leverage in the relationship because i
made one mistake
we're going to couples counseling twice
a week and it's really helped clear the
air and get something back on track
but it's been very one-sided yeah well
dude you gotta you gotta i don't know
you're coming off a little selfish here
if you did what you did
you know i don't know dude
my gut's telling me you shouldn't get
married
anyways because you haven't said that
you really love this woman at all
for example i've confided in several my
best friends that were on the trip
through text messages and of course i
delete them because it's a conversation
i wouldn't want her to see
it's bro talk that would undoubtedly be
taken out of context and start a fight
oh boy buddy my fiance goes through my
phone and sees that i'm deleting texts
and tells my accounts our counselor
about yeah dude this relationship is
over
um because i was basically told that i
can't delete text and i have to be
transparent if i want this to work and
our counselor
agreed uh yeah prior to my cheating she
never went through my phone at all so
this is
uncharted waters for me i'm walking on
eggshells and it [ __ ] sucks she wants
me to cut ties with the majority of my
best friends that
that were on the trip and that's not
going to happen yeah it's over
i love my fiance okay it's here i want
to marry her
and i want to be with her for the rest
of my life she's an incredible beautiful
woman and i wish i could take back what
i did
i made the mistake and i'm the reason i
am in this situation all right you've
taken accountability here
but i don't think i can be too much of a
pushover in the
in this process i know i have to give in
a bit here but i feel like i have to
draw a line at some point
should i give up my bachelor trip
because it's what she wants
yeah dude i think you have to you have
to say i already had mine
um or do you have any advice for me to
make a bachelor trip happen with my best
friend
that she now hates yeah dude i i just i
don't see this relationship working
um i think you're
sad that you did what you did i think
you feel
bad that you hurt her but i also think
that you
probably equally feel bad for yourself
so um
i don't know and then you're texting
what are you texting
don't you see the tits on that chick i
mean if that's what you're texting
during all of this um i think you
getting caught
might have saved you a lot of money
um and kids that will [ __ ] resent you
or whatever i i just don't think you
should
i don't think she'd get married
um i think your only play here is just
to say look how long are you gonna
[ __ ] i know i put myself in this
situation but
like you totally don't trust me you're
going through my phone and this is this
level of control is going to drive me
crazy after a while
but then you also already [ __ ] up by
having to delete text so she once again
she's broken the trust with her again
it's over dude it's a wrap either you
put your balls in her purse or you
[ __ ] walk
so either get used to this and
uh not have a bachelor party the fact
that you still think you deserve one is
pretty [ __ ] up
i gotta be honest with you so i don't
think you're at the level of maturity or
maybe
with the right person yet to get married
so if i was you
uh i'm leaning i would say get the [ __ ]
out now cause it's not gonna get any
better
all right should i get a prenup dear
billy the bulbar i'm a 27 year old
entrepreneur and i'm engaged my fiance
is 21. we've been dating for almost one
and a half years
i met her when she was 17. she's only
17.
uh when i was working in a minimum wage
job trying to start up a business
i was kind of i was kind of friend zoned
but then perhaps
that was because she was in high school
um all right well wait a second
you were 27 weren't you friend zoned
cause you were 10 years older than her
because she was old as jim morrison when
he died and she was still [ __ ]
uh still had a book bag
all right when i met her well i don't
know
when i met her i'm i made about 12 000
12 000 per year and lived with my
parents but after starting my business i
made
160 grand in my first year and 180 grand
in my second year
the business is just opening up two more
locations in 2022
and continued to expanding after that we
didn't start dating until after i was
making money
uh yeah she was also a kid dude when you
met her so i see where you're going with
this but she was a [ __ ]
i mean 17 years
my parents insist that i'm crazy if i
don't get a prenuptial
prenuptial agreement as an argument
could be made that my company is very
valuable
and when i brought this up to her she
felt very insulted like i was indicating
she was only in it for the money yeah
that's the thing with prenups there's no
way to bring it up where they're not
going to get pissed
i said i don't think that it's just to
appease my parents
ah that was a stupid thing to say then
she thought i was saying
my parents don't trust her see now
you're into that she probably signed it
if i forced her but would resent me for
it
a little history on my girl she was
physically abused as a child
and the father eventually left the
family she had a very long
sexual history before meeting me
though she met her at seventeen two
these these [ __ ] emails are too deep
this is above my pay grade people
and according to her i was the first
person she told about her sexual history
in depth and one of the
one of only a few to know about the
abuse
um all right so she trusts you that's a
good thing since we've been together she
hasn't if she's telling the truth
because i don't know any of these people
in this story i don't know you
since we've been together she hasn't
given me any reason to doubt her i'd say
doubt her i'd say her behavior is the
opposite of gold digging she encourages
me not to spend money
on her as she says she doesn't deserve
someone like me
um i can see my parent brother's
extended family's perspective but they
don't know
her like i know her and it seems wrong
to say hey i love you
and want to spend the rest of my life
with you but just in case you're
planning on running off my money sign
this
any advice would be appreciated um
oh jesus i mean i don't know what to
tell you i mean this is like one of the
things that they don't talk about
in the current narrative where how
um
where as a man how you're just always
viewed as the predator but the thing is
when you become rich and successful you
become prey
you do and there's way more women that
will now have a conversation with you
because of where you're at the car
you're driving and the clothes you're
wearing now i understand their argument
was like well i'm not gonna hit my wagon
as some [ __ ] loser
but the you know the same way guys will
marry for looks some guys will do that
some people
women will marry for the lifestyle
so this is something that you're gonna
have to try
and figure out yeah there's prenups
there's [ __ ]
i don't know what else is there trust
she's pretty young dude i would be
nervous
that like wait you're 10 years older so
she's 21 so you're 31.
you got this crazy [ __ ] business
going
and she's gonna marry into that and
she's 21 years old
she could hang with you for five years
let that [ __ ] blow up
and she still has the rest of her
[ __ ] 20s
to take that money and then try to go
out and find love yeah i mean i can see
why your parents are putting that
paranoid [ __ ] in your head
um but i'm not going to tell you what to
do here dude this this is way too
complex
all right um
all right ladies you know what can any
ladies out there ladies how how does a
guy in that situation
know what is and and be brutally
honest because you know i was joking
about this i did conan last week there's
like
women out here that can tell
instantly if the ferrari is yours if you
rented
or rented it there's a sticker somewhere
they they just look and they know like
oh he's just
he doesn't have ferrari money if they
see you without that sticker then
they're like ah
you know and then they move on right
to the guy who actually has the ferrari
so there is that element out there is
this person that i have no idea
there's no way for me to tell so
somebody out there
uh ladies can you read from your
playbook a little bit
how can this guy um
tell if just this woman's
being honest with them i mean those are
some good signs you know don't
don't buy me anything i don't [ __ ]
deserve it blah blah blah i mean i think
that's [ __ ]
trauma from her childhood which you know
if you get abused like that you feel
[ __ ] worthless
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know guys
come on let's just let's try to keep it
light here all right but ladies write in
let me know okay let this guy know he's
in a critical point here okay that's the
podcast
go bruins go celtics go red sox go [ __ ]
yourselves
and i will check in on you on thursday
you